here against team teal as the Canadians send it
around Mike Mat number eight working up to Alex
new hook who turns it over and declair Records the
shot on goal a higher points percentage against
this franchise than any other in the league here's
Mike Hoffman ahead to cunan and a save by Primo
and then off the rebound it's for the Sharks
two-on one good acceleration down that right
side pulls it to the forehand finds a little
Gap there underneath the stick into cun and
right there you can see the rebound coming back
to to Hopman as it comes off the goenda Primo
right prevented in doing so by McDonald now
mat goes right wing side Suzuki on the wing
and a shot saved by mckeny Blackwood 82 games
that he played that's a nightly leadership that
he's provided kova Savage keeping it in at the
right Point side blackw a blocker save Primo was
making the stops earlier in the period kova s
now that one's blocked in the slot picked back
up by Coffield for Montreal and Blackwood diving
across again he's second overall in scoring for
Montreal as they are led by Suzuki 17 another save
for Blackwood this is one of the dangerous lines
for Montreal morak puts it on the net Blackwood
with a save there Hopman and here's a chance
in Fr in Blackwood with a big save off Tanner
Pearson and McKenzie blackwood's been the best
shark Kaden strubel number 47 on defense here for
Montreal gets it to the net saved by Blackwood as
Cofield tried to punch home the rebound now
in his 20th game this season Anderson hasn't
scored yet here's a shot from mat right into the
chest of McKenzie Blackwood organization is where
you got to start here's nio stur out the last
two games and he's held going to be a penalty
on this there's a goal and cunan denied by Primo
on the 2on one side holding and now he's got the
two-on one cunan on your left hand side trying to
drive the net gets the one time kind of shoots it
back into Primo trying to go against the grain
I don't mind this play but look at the strength
from Sturm right here just gets his arm in one
position throws mat back drives to the puck s
pass into C of to Drive Addison and grin again
on the wing it's hurdle hurdle back hand Primo
the save rebound and Primo gets back again
spread eagle Save By The Young goendale kayen
Primo carraro puts it on n and that's saved by
Primo back to Pearson and he lost it to hurdle
nice takeway by 48 and now Eckland working out
of the corner he'll bring It Around the Net he
has Hoffman who scores happy birthday Mike
Hoffman the sharks with a one- nothing lead
this is just a good play a little reverse but
this play is a 50/50 right there hurdle tries
to go against the grain but watch the sharks
they end up getting this puck back shot then
retrieval this is the one that makes the goal
right here that turnover by hurdle he's going
to cut back a little soft pass into i' love
that Stutter Step by eckan and then he finds
the passing Lane out front to Hoffman who's a
sniper and finally starting to get more shots
on goal we broke him down in the open you
have to do is talk to someone who's played
there and there's a goal for Ean and it's two
[Music] [Applause] nothing right off the face
off and it's a power play goal off of faceoffs
they wanted a pass they want a shot they want
retrieval right off the face off ecklin peels off
on the one time and boy goes top Corner Against
the Grain beautiful pass by Addison and then just
the rest is left up to the young forward from the
Sharks eckan going far down here on a power
play goal fourth goal dorak over to Coffield
now back at the line kova Savage he'll load up
fire and score Jonathan kova Savage picks the
top corner on McKenzie Blackwood Montreal
breaks through and it's two to [Applause]
one about 2 minutes to get out of this period he
would up nothing and it was a push by Montreal
and and it was a push by Montreal and too many
turnovers by the sharks in this consecutive
shifts they get it out to the point zelin goes
over now they got the pass over to kovich he's
got time and space and blackwood's got his own
defenseman there as ohu kind of goes down in
front of him gets it by him he's just kind of
hoping and praying it hits his body and a save
by Primo a great play by hurdle oh boy two
onone now for Montreal the shot and the goal
Cole Coffield and Montreal ties it [Applause] up
Coffield had a chance in the first Blackwood stop
and somewhere he solves Blackwood here to tie the
game gets his head up looking for that two-on-one
to pass no elex to shoot pull the trigger beats
him to The Far Side this is sixth of the season
for Coffield and gets his head up and finds the
corner it's just a beautiful shot by the young
forward by Montreal is dorak reaching back
and working that to the P caring defenseman
mat he's got it to Coffield and alone saved
by McKenzie Blackwood and dor wins the draw
now he goes to the bench and then in behind
hurdle doesn't see Coffield coming off the
bench and he scored nice move by eckan
to get the first goal of the shootout
for the Sharks here is the Montreal
captain now to try and level the
score and he does what a sweet move great Hands
by Suzuki comes in slows it down changes his
speed look like he's going to shot gives a
little bit of a head fake and then he pulls
it on the back hand boy he's got all that net to
put it into what a move by Suzuki in this season
slaps it right to the mid of Primo
talked about use your strengths is one
of my lean into your strengths is one
of your keys here tonight my keys and
look at going trying to go top corner
and Primo makes the glove [Applause]
save and another save for McKenzie Blackwood but
D'Or had a strong game in the faceof circle won
that opening face off play and he comes in
on this one and Blackwood what a stop there
with the right with speed the Fain and the
backand is wide oh my I thought he had him
I thought he had him too even Primo was
down and out looked like the backand was
wide open and not sure if Primo gets a glove
on this or not but right there look it pulls
it here and yeah I think he gets a little
piece of that on the on the glove from the
hurdle pull drag on the back end 29-year-old sha
Monahan the veteran to try and win it here for
Montreal and Blackwood there with the
blocker Anthony duclair stepping over Monahan
the veteran coming in Blackwood just perfect
there Square to that shot gets a Blocker on it
we begin round six Anthony declair against Hayden
primo and unsuccessful as it stays tied
here in the shootout 1-1 Clair coming in
that right to left looking to fake that
shot pull on the back end Primo gets
that left pad on number 56 yie Al yessie
Alon now for Montreal we're into the six
round and he scores and Montreal completes
the comeback as they win it here in the
sixth round of a shootout yes to yonan
with the shootout deciding goal here
in San Jose you hate to lose these at
home or anytime well yonan right here
is going to pull it to the back and then
back to the for and it's just a really